ah
vivir en el internet y del internet
no es tarea fácil y menos si tu trabajo
es crear contenido para ciertas
plataformas
hace unos años una chavita mientras
estaba en el super me pidió una foto
y como de costumbre yo accedí pero la
niña no traía su celular y me dijo oye
baby se ha quedado dos minutos muy por
mi mamá
dije sí claro
no pasaron ni tres minutos y la chavita
ya había regresado al mismo pasillo
donde estábamos pero con la mamá
no les voy a mentir no me encantó el
feeling de la señora como que no estaba
ya sabes como cuando sientes que no está
feliz de verte
algo así
nos toma la foto de la señora y chico
pleito
en alguna ocasión yo antes de entrar a
el cine pues yo soy de los que compran
sus palomitas su refresco sus dulces y
al momento de querer entrar yo querer
entrar a la sala resulta que me dice el
chavo que te corta el boletito no joven
perdón todavía no puede pasar
cómo
son 750 amigos mi boleto 17 y media le
hice un pancho innecesario la verdad
le dije me dice es que estamos
retrasados y todas las funciones se
retrasa esto es culpa del cine no es mi
culpa
yo quiero entrar yo compré mi boleto
quiero sentarme quiero relajarme quiero
comer se olvidó que hice un pancho
mucha gente me preguntaba por qué
empezaste a hacer vídeos cómo empezaste
porque la verdad es que cada quien
empieza a hacer distintas cosas por
distintos motivos la mía era muy
sencilla yo empiezo a hacer vídeos
porque necesitaba autoterapia armé
porque porque no estaba pasando por un
muy buen momento mis papás se estaban
divorciando
yo acababa de regresar de eeuu no tenía
yo amigos en mi escuela y pues fue así
como conozco youtube y me comienzo a
relacionar con extraños cosas que no
recomiendo ahorita no lo hagan pero
comienzo yo a platicar con extraños y
les contaba mi problema si ellos me
encontraban los suyos y viceversa
y youtube se convierte en mi zona de
confort muy fuerte
estamos hablando que esto fue hace 12
años
yo no sabía el impacto que tenía el
internet yo contrabajo y entendía el
internet o que era el internet o cómo me
conectaba
yo solía subir vídeos en ese entonces
con shock o la chava que nos ayuda nos
ayudaba en la casa y la verdad es que
eso ccoo era mi mejor amiga muchos lo
entienden esa relación pero el mejor
amiga nos llevábamos fatal
fatal nos decíamos de cosas arriba abajo
pero éramos muy amigos así nos
llevábamos
si yo hoy por hoy hicieron un vídeo como
los que yo hacía con sokol a gente me
linchan
no la gente come lynch haría imposible y
son esos vídeos antiguos que hoy por hoy
yo veo y digo más allá maduras para que
más bien en la vida ganando
pero las cosas empiezan a cambiar cuando
yo empiezo a hacer cosas en vivo primero
viene un meet and greet en una plaza
a la que según yo iban cinco personas
fueron mil luego vino un show en la
feria estatal a la cual fueron casi tres
mil personas
o sea en ese momento yo dije como esta
gente pagó un boleto por verme a mí y yo
dije si va mi mamá mi papá ya la hice
lista también están imprimiendo los
boletos con eso da por bien servido
pero no fue en ese momento fue que yo
dije a las responsabilidades grande
esto te está sobrepasando
no nada más te están viendo oyendo
juzgando que están escuchando
llegó un punto en el que yo dije en mi
canal ya no es un espacio de juego en el
que yo me estoy auto terapia no es un
salón de clases
es lo que yo diga le va a llegar a mucha
persona que quiero dejarles
un octubre hace años hice un vídeo que
se llamaba toca este chico
y del personaje de la tía lee es el
personaje de mi mamá con su comadre
brittany yajaira donde en realidad les
enseñan a cómo tocarse y analizarse
inspeccionarse y fundido que me gustó
mucho porque trata un tema muy
importante era no chica pero graciosa
digerible
sin quitarle la importancia que debiera
en ese tema
semanas después nos escribe una chava
diciendo gracias tu vídeo me detectaron
cáncer de mama y me estoy es que están
tratando
o sea yo yo sentí así como qué
ok de nada o sea que padre de igual
manera sentí la responsabilidad de hacer
un vídeo sobre el bullying porque si
bien el canal de gobier siempre ha sido
como que para que te des ya sabe usted
ese estrés es de las cosas que ves en
facebook o de las malas noticias o sea
queremos skierkier entretenerte pero
sentía yo una vez más esa
responsabilidad de tener que hablar de
cierto tema
nunca nadie obligó a contarles cómo
cuándo por qué y dónde salir del closet
pero sin embargo era muchísima la gente
que me escribía diciéndome wadir como te
terminaste de aceptar esa pregunta me
movió bastante el internet es un arma de
doble filo
eso eso aprendan se lo
resulta que un buen día checando yo los
mensajes de mi página de facebook pero
que había uno que decía disculpas yo
dije mal quién se va a disculpar de qué
era el chavo del cine aquí por alguna
razón yo había sido innecesariamente
grosero pretente y sin embargo el chavo
se estaba disculpando
por haberme hecho pasar un mal rato
para empezar yo me sentí fatal porque él
no se debería estar disculpado él
simplemente estaba haciendo su trabajo y
por alguna razón yo sentí la libertad de
ser grosero y prepotente
el problema empieza cuando mucha gente
que está de la pantalla cree que por
vernos diario somos sus amigos nos
conocen somos parte de su familia cuando
en realidad no te conocen no sé quién
está del otro lado de la pantalla y son
estas mismas personas las que me han
dado todo en mi vida una casa el mejor
trabajo que podría tener viajes
experiencias
y les repito porque es importante el
internet es un arma de doble filo que
puede abrir muchas puertas y traer
beneficios que podría acabar así
beneficios que me ha traído algunos de
los beneficios que a mí me ha traído el
internet
95 ó 99 por ciento de mis amigos hoy por
hoy los conocí gracias a youtube
donde las pasamos viajando a cada rato
nunca o muy rara vez estamos en la misma
ciudad pero cuando estamos nena se arma
se arma
tuve el privilegio y el honor de
entrevistar a mel gibson young & go will
ferrell mark whalberg actores de
hollywood de muchas películas que estoy
muy seguro ustedes ubican
y mi cereza del pastel es creo que lo
más chocante que me ha pasado
abrace a ellen degeneres
ay
no nada más la frase a la un liso olor
de ver a su olor de naranja y vainilla
te impregna y dices guay es verdad
calientita ella ya sabes increíble
regresando al tema de la señora que yo
les contaba al principio la señora del
super resulta que esta señora había sido
mi víctima en algún vídeo
como móvil
y antes solía ir mucho al súper poco y
les mostraba todo lo que yo compraba con
mi celular
y si te respeta el momento de editar yo
veía que en el fondo de ese vídeo había
una persona como que juzgando me dijo
qué hace ese niño yo lo único que hacía
era si un superzoom a la persona le
ponía blanco y negro una música
misteriosa y lo dejaba cuatro segundos
ya sabes a mí me encantaba me divertía
pues la señora
que les dio fe fue una de mis víctimas
he de admitir que la señora no se veía
bien en ese vídeo se veía cansada como
que se acababa de despertar marca de
almohada
y no lo estaba pasando muy bien porque
la señora resulta que en ese momento de
su vida tenía cáncer
y yo ni enterado
y a mí se me hizo muy gracioso editar de
esa manera y subirlo
las compañeras porque no eran amigas las
compañeras de la hija
en el vídeo
reconocen a la señora
y se empiezan a burlar de la señora
empiezan a hacer bullying horrible a la
hija
esa es la experiencia más fuerte que me
ha dejado el internet y todo porque yo
decidí subirlo porque a mí se me hizo
gracioso
muchos se van a preguntar guabirá y cómo
lo sabes hi hija porque cuando nos tomó
la foto la señora me cantó mi cartilla
en el pasillo 3
igual viven acá
yo no te debería estar tomando esa foto
porque por tu culpa yo tuve que sacar a
mi hija de esa escuela
porque por tu culpa a mi hija lloro
mucho
cuando de cajón ya no le estábamos
pasando nada bien por la condición de la
señora
yo congelado
y me dijo pero te tengo que agradecer
porque si no hubiese sido por ese vídeo
yo no hubiese sacado a mi hija de esa
escuela y mi hija hoy por hoy está en un
lugar mejor con amigas y mi hija es
feliz
twitter instagram facebook youtube la
red social que ustedes quieran
son de doble filo o te puede traer
muchos beneficios o te puede acabar y
destrozar
créanme cuando les digo después de 12
años lo aprendido créanme piensen no una
no tres diez veces antes de subir algo a
las redes sociales
porque nunca vamos a saber en realidad
quién está del otro lado de la pantalla
mirando
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]